[Music]
today on stick to football we're live
from tuning Brewing Company in
Indianapolis Indiana our third annual
hangout here at the combine guys awesome
beer on tap we have a very quiet crowd
normally like there's some rustling in
the background and they're all just
sitting there staring at us right now
which is really really fun there we go
hey whoever started that you get another
free beer but combine week thank the
Lord above is almost over ready to sleep
in my own bed love Indianapolis but it
has been it's been a long week it's
taking its toll and what we want to do
is we have a live audience today we know
a lot of those guys want to talk about
rumors we're gonna do that we're gonna
take live draft on draft questions and
we have the funniest person on Twitter
hands down I'm here mellowes if we also
have Joey Molinaro who is amazing if
you're not following him on Twitter do
it right now when you're listening to
the show or if you're sitting the
audience go do it right now I see Dan
Barnes on his phone that better be what
you're doing to the letter the yang gang
right yeah he's trying to get getting
back in the election right now so we are
we're gonna talk to Joey it's gonna be a
great time can't wait for that interview
but boys let's kick it off right here it
has been a crazy week
the hardest part for me ten years in
this job is to come down here and you
spend all this time talking to coaches
and scouts and agents and you try to
just basically cut through the BS so I
don't know if we can curse in here you
just cut through the bar yes of what
you're being told and it was funny
yesterday Friday you'll have one person
come to and be like hey this offensive
tackle failed the Wonderlic and it's
like well I don't know how that's
possible but okay and then you hear from
another one like he had the best
interview we've ever seen so going
through the BS a little bit I just want
to talk about some of the rumors that
are out there and get the read from the
desk here on how we see these things
let's start here Matthew Stafford may be
pushing his way out of Detroit this is
something we've spent a lot of time
talking about a guy who the Detroit
Lions will pay thirty million dollars in
2020 regardless of if he's on the team
or not
I have said for weeks now that I think
Matt Stafford is untradable but if he
forces his way out we've seen this with
Antonio Brown with Jalen Ramsey we've
seen guys do it if Matt Stafford pushes
it that for Melo number one do you think
it's possible number two where does he
go I don't blame him you're looking at
that Detroit team and I'm sorry if we
have any Detroit fan
in the house but they're going nowhere
fast and they're also in a position
right now drafting at number three
overall if tua is sitting there at three
which he might not be I think that
Detroit lines would be very wise to take
a chance on that we've been waiting all
along for two and the medicals to come
back and they came back and now
Washington's talking about him Detroit
might be talking about him so maybe Matt
Stafford sees the writing on the wall
and maybe he wants to go actually play
for a contender there are a lot of good
teams that need a quarterback
Indianapolis Tampa Bay a lot of teams
that he would fit the mold for at
quarterback so maybe he just wants to
get out of shorty well he still has a
couple years left yeah and you take away
the the biggest issue which is probably
the contract I think that's what would
be the hold up in trades and it's
probably the best time for both sides to
actually have it divorce here because
you have Stafford who's coming off a
season where you know he's riddled with
his back injury probably understands
that his window to win now is in these
next four years as a 31 year old
quarterback I play utmost and it got
exactly especially when you're banged up
and a guy that's played at a really high
level and he probably feels hey Detroit
hasn't gotten it done for me and if your
Detroit you're sitting there in a window
where you're picking in a range where
you can get a really good quarterback
right now and also I actually think you
can get a return on Stafford that would
help your team or help rebuild this team
we've seen Matt Patricius ship out some
veterans I'm not a believer that Darius
slay is gonna be there for the long term
right now and I know they asked Matt
Patricia on the broadcast last night
Rich Eisen did a great job with all the
interviews but he asked me you know
where are these rumors coming from about
Stafford and Patricia did the right
thing and said listen people are bored
they're making stuff up but I just feel
like we've heard so much noise around
this guy's at this point it's almost
like where there's smoke there might
actually be a little fire here in
Detroit if you're Detroit this is risky
though because say you trade Matt
Stafford when the league you're opens in
two weeks you don't know that you're
getting to it at three so you've put
yourself in a position you have to like
Justin Herbert as much exact too or you
have to like Jordan love as much as you
like the other quarterbacks because you
can't just assume the two is gonna be
there so even if you look at it and say
well tua is an upgrade over Matthew
Stafford he's younger he's gonna be more
he's gonna be cheaper we can actually
build a team around him you don't know
that you're getting that player so I
think that's the riskier I actually
don't buy this rumor at all and maybe
I'm just old and skeptical I don't think
you can
a player who's gonna count 30 million
dollars against your salary cap I don't
this problem yeah off the bat and then
also on top of that like I mean do you
really like Justin hurt that much more
than Matthew Stafford or they're gonna
do with the dolphins dead and they're
gonna wait a year and save me and I
don't really like to eat questionable
health that Trevor Lawrence kid looks
pretty [ __ ] good
okay what the Lions have done before
they'll go winless and put themselves in
a position to get a guy like Jeff a CUDA
at corner and then draft Trevor Lawrence
luck next year
well if anyone can put a plan in place
for that right now it is the Lions
because first off I agree with you
Justin Herbert's not the answer over
Matt Stafford for me in the slightest
bit that's not even oh how I feel that's
not an option on the table at all but
they're sitting there at three they
actually might be in a prime spot for a
trade back opportunity and maybe they
sit there and say hey we don't actually
want a lot of your picks right now we
want them next year and you start
building all this draft capital maybe
you get some more when you move Darius
slay now you're sitting there and you
can kind of control the 2021 giraffe but
also the problem is that coaching staff
has no security where they can't feel
very comfortable doing a long-term
coaching the win you don't usually try
to they have to win this year right guys
the owners yeah and let's move on here
Mike silver comes on says the Washington
Redskins are serious about taking to a
ton of I'll owe it to it's not just
smoke they have said themselves they're
gonna bring in Joe burrow they're gonna
bring into a and it's not just doing due
diligence they want all options are on
the table and so I think even with
Detroit this ties into that because
again you have no guarantee and even
their trade market Detroit's ability to
trade the third pick hinges on to of
being there so if two is gone at two and
we set it on the Friday show Connor and
I did
mellow I love your take that to is such
a massive upgrade over between Haskins
in my opinion and this is nothing it's a
good player but two is so much better
than him if he's healthy that I think
you actually have to consider it the I
want to say this they don't have a
second round pick so this could also be
a little bit of posturing where they're
hoping someone comes up to get to a and
they're okay getting a CUDA at five
instead of getting chase young at two or
they're okay getting Jedrek wills or
Makai Becton so this could be posturing
without that second round pick Melo
you have the choice between two in
Haskins he taken I think it's easy it's
to uh I mean no questions asked and we
saw the Cardinals do this last year when
they took Kyler Mary it was here in
Indianapolis what do we think
that was gonna happen so it wouldn't
shock me at all I know that when the
Cardinals pulled the trigger on it it
was shocking because I they just drafted
a quarterback
well now you can see that he was
shocking like people who weren't
listening to this podcast in Haskins I
don't think he played that well his
first year it's a new coaching staff I
thought he should have been like a
second round pick last year I was not a
fan Haskins so if two is sitting there
and you feel confident with what you
have at the edge position with guys like
sweat I mean they're loaded on defense
so maybe they do kick the tires at least
on tour and see how is this gonna fit
into our long-term plan because Ron
Rivera is gonna be there for a few right
and if you can get a 2021 first round
here by trading back you got to do it
yeah yeah even if they do move out of
the second pick maybe they can still
maybe they're saying man we really like
Jeff Okuda we don't want to take him it
too let's see if we can move to four or
five or you know some of these other
teams that need to move up for a
quarterback and I'll say this about
Haskins job security let's not forget
guys Ron Rivera went to the Redskins
because now this is a coach controlled
organization it's something that VP of
player personnel Kyle Smith even said
here at the combine this week or the
owner obviously to Dan Snyder it really
is Ron Rivera and then moving down and
let's not forget last year we saw a
similar situation
Kliff Kingsbury goes to Arizona he makes
the decisions there that are this high
impact decisions over the GM so if
they're not sold on Haskins from what
they learn or what and apparently these
conversations have gone on a lot longer
than we originally thought then it's
completely possible that they take a
quarterback second overall I like to was
talent just as much as I like Joe
Barroso you don't have to sell me
anything on that at all I think it would
be you know a really polarizing decision
because chase young is on the board and
that's the safer option but at the end
of the day it's a really big upgrade at
quarterback and if you're Ron Rivera
you're coming into this job you have no
ties to any player on this roster you
know lately start over and I think there
will be people to say well you just
drafted a quarterback last year you
don't really get to seal out of him why
are you having on if you don't like that
quarterback you can't keep them or if
you don't think that you can win with
them you can't keep them you got to move
on quarterbacks like to it don't come
around very often I know that Joe
burrows sitting there this year but
outside of those two guys
the rest of the board I'm not taking
them in the first not doing it there's
no way so I think that you do have to
jump on one of these guys you don't want
to be the Cleveland Browns who sit
around and pass on every good
quarterback like a Patrick mahomes or
deshaun Watson or some of these other
really good quarterbacks and now you're
stuck with ol number six there yeah your
best friend Baker Mayfield this this
transition and getting although out of
trouble here the Arizona Cardinals you
mentioned it Connor that there's a coach
driven organization out Kliff Kingsbury
one thing I've heard throughout the week
guys this should not be a surprise to
anyone is that they are very invested in
the offense so offensive tackle class
and this year's draft they did just sign
DJ Humphrey steer three extension but
they need another offensive tackle after
what we saw christen wharfs do in a
record-setting performance on Friday
night he's a player we've linked to them
for weeks now I'm starting to feel
really good about that pick for them if
Jedrek wills is off the board already so
I had some hot takes on the offensive
line class this year or I said I didn't
really like the tackles I didn't know if
Tristan worms could move that well and
Wow was I wrong so I think that if he
falls to the Cardinals they have to jump
on him but I think we're gonna see two
if not three offensive linemen go on the
top ten now I think so too and I think
worse is the perfect pick when you look
at this Arizona team that needs to build
an offensive line me and Matt we're
we're joking a bit yesterday that I
don't think you could put Makai Becton
in front of Kyler Murray so that would
be kind of interesting we'd never see
him again as Madison the hide behind his
leg listen I I liked worse as the
second-best tackle in this class not a
guard not moving him out of that tackle
spot like I miss a tackle so Jedrek
wills Tristan works here's the crazy
thing I don't think any of the top
offensive lineman lost at the combine
they all won even Andrew Thomas comes in
longer arms than we thought moved better
than he thought he obviously interviews
really well very very smart guy so when
you look at how this board Falls now
you're gonna have wills wharfs Becton
Thomas probably Jones in the mix and
Brett you keep saying it Austin Jackson
is really on the rise right and I had
some I tweeted before he came over here
today to do the show was that this we've
four quarterbacks could go very early
for offensive tackles are going to go
very early jerry judy and CD lamb are
gonna fall mm-hmm and it's something we
have we've discussed hopin let's go hurt
the receiver
a little bit you could hurt this
receiver custody some I say a Simmons if
he fell to nine I would not be shocked
now if he went third I wouldn't be
surprised but he could fall in this
draft because we're seeing now these
tackles lived up to expectations and
mellow I was there with you at the
Senior Bowl because at the time we were
talking about his worth to guard is he a
tackle and I tweeted the same things
like I'm not in love with this I had
three at the time Josh Jones has played
his way up Austin Jackson has definitely
played his way up so we could see five
tackles go in the first round no the
team addressing big areas of need here
the Green Bay Packers I've heard and we
talked about early in the week they were
all over the tight ends they have met
with every top linebacker in this class
and not just your casual hey what's your
number we might call you on draft day
like very formal interviews they're
setting up meetings down the road so the
Packers at linebacker Blake Martinez is
a free agent
it's a gaping hole in the middle of that
defense for a team that actually has
drafted really really well since Ted
Thompson retired and Brian took over the
job there so any of the Packers that
linebacker buzz it's real and we're
gonna see it today Saturday with these
workouts if Patrick Queen and Kenneth
Murray run themselves out of the 30th
pick in the draft exactly and I think
that's it they are in good position
right now but there's so many teams at
the back end of the first round that
need one of these linebackers I think
there are three very good first-round
linebackers Green Bay might have to move
up to get one though because I do expect
Patrick Queen to run very well and I
actually expect Kenneth Murray to run
very well also so I don't know that
either one of them will be there at 30
but you also have guys like Malik
Harrison out of Ohio State you have Troy
dye I like him quite a bit to Jordan
Brooks Zach bond I view him as a
linebacker I don't know if he can play
that middle linebacker spot yet but he's
another guy that maybe could slide in
there 30 overall and I think what'll
dictate all that is when does Isaiah
Simmons come off the board because like
you said if he goes in the top ten then
you're gonna probably see teams like Las
Vegas now the Raiders look at Patrick
Queen and Kenneth Murray earlier than we
even expected so it's interesting how
they run today how they test today will
really dictate that but I think the
point is there's a really really nice
upper tier of off ball linebackers in
this class now definitely and I think
tamela's point there's some depth in it
let's run through these two pretty
quickly
bright fire and Jones gonna hit the free
agent market Cowboys we've known this
for a while if you're gonna keep dak and
you're gonna keep them re Cooper and
they've basically said they're gonna
hag DAC if they can't get a deal done
somebody's gotta go it's gonna be Byron
Jones
I think the Giants make a ton of sense
for him I think the Eagles make a ton of
sense for him
Connors New York Jets make a ton of
sense for him sorry your Chiefs have no
money no perfect in that scheme but yeah
it's not gonna happen not gonna happen
but it feels like he's gonna be going to
the East Coast real soon we think he get
against twenty million dollars a year
he's gonna push close I think 18 I think
this free agent market is gonna be
literally out of control it's gonna get
that Tony Romo money yeah high 17 mil
per year I mean do you believe that a
million dollars a game great good all
right that's good for him yeah but
that's crazy I don't know why people are
hating on it that's capitalism it's good
in sports media for other people to be
getting paid a lot of money and gonna
have to read negotiate Micha ing
watching games called by Tony Romo it
also has nothing to do with the CBA that
was a weird yeah thing going on on
Twitter tight in well its tight in.if
CBS keeps the TV if they keep NFL then
his deal runs seven years if they don't
it's three years so it's so it could be
a tenure deal thanks guys how that works
yeah I don't like watching Tony Romo
games there's no way I would pay 17
million to watch that guy I don't have
it so I don't have to worry about that
I don't I just I'm over the stick of
Tony Romo so I don't like I a Chiefs fan
I have to watch CBS games and I don't
care for him it's tough well you're
gonna be living in a primetime world
right right of Monday Night Football
okay you get booger and Joe on Monday
night yeah yeah enjoy that last one here
for you before we get into some of the
work that's my gosh we have a long show
here today some of the workouts we'll
get to but Shaq Barrett franchise tag is
coming and this put me in Jameis Winston
cannot be tagged guys and that's that's
why this is notable Bruce Arians that
thought was great this week he was like
yet like 20 of those picks were his
fault 10 weren't not really the world
you want to live in and he keeps saying
things too like yeah there's a
quarterback out there that can play
better than Jameis Winston and if we can
get him we're going to it's almost like
he has his eye on somebody in the draft
he doesn't know if his team can move up
yet but if that quarterback happens to
fall to him yeah you bet your butt
they're gonna pull the trigger on it I
mean take some how little of a [ __ ] does
Bruce give about whether Jameis comes
back
not yeah I'm buying everything he's
saying he's like yeah yeah well look
into tom we're gonna Philip Rivers you
know Jameis all these pics were his
fault I mean it's good leveraging
because now you're not he's not gonna
pay Jameis Winston whatever 30 plus is
when you've broken up and like you're
still talking and like you're still
hanging out every now and then but
you're definitely on tinder like you're
still swiping on other people that's
Bruce Arians right now oh yeah like if
there's anything else better out there
I'm doing this there's gonna be before
we end this segment good or bad decision
to move on from James Bond good yeah
good even with the LASIK I'm with you
not working for me
take a break we come back we are gonna
give you some of our favorite
performances from the combine
I've Joey Molinaro then your draft on
draft questions live at two deep rowing
company we'll be back right after this
we are back live from tunic Brewing
Company in Indianapolis Indiana that is
a mouthful we want to talk about some of
the best performances I don't want to
call this winners and losers but some of
the best performances we've seen this
week of the combine we've talked about
the offensive linemen a little bit in
the first segment everyone was
impressive Tristan Dwarfs had a
record-setting performance makai Becton
weighs about a hundred and a lot more
pounds than me and ran a 5-1 140 which
should not happen that's not normal
Jedrek wills good workout very good
workout Andrew Thomas did as well like
Connor said Caesar Ruiz I think
submitted himself as the top interior
offensive lineman in this class we're
gonna see where season linemen go in the
first round robin ea7 could be in the
first round but the running backs ran on
Friday night and the combine going to
prime time that's what it's about it's
about the receivers and the running
backs running a prime-time they did not
disappoint especially mr. Jonathan
Taylor knew it was coming
it's one of those things where we knew
he was fast but you want to see it
confirmed and you want it it's like he's
226 pounds to 120 pounds like that it's
a big guy and so you just want to see
that number confirmed and oh my did he
do it yeah and I think you mentioned it
too with the size no other running back
is running at that speed with this size
not not this year I know that we've had
others like sacrum Marseille Quan Zeke
like the top two your running backs and
that's why I think that a lot of these
running backs
I know Edwards Hilaire didn't run that
well for six doesn't bother me
deandre swift running very well cam
Akers - we haven't seen JK Dobbins yet
I think the running backs made
themselves a lot of money this week
and because they all ran and performed
very well to come by and I think we have
to have a conversation now about AJ
Dillon I was gonna say I mean I know
obviously the production at Boston
College was huge feel like they gave me
the ball 60 times again I mean just hit
run straight and any runs through people
but I thought the testing numbers for
someone that's 247 pounds
we're phenomenal for a while I just felt
like yeah maybe six seventh round
someone takes a flyer on him I actually
think he's somebody that made himself a
lot of money here in Indy especially
when some of the players we were putting
him in tears with didn't perform like
Javon leek was really disappointing
athletically
if AJ Dillon is not a Tennessee Titan at
the end of the draft I will be shocked
like it really just feels like that's
Derek Henry and maybe not to that level
but like that stare can raise a little
brother yeah and they just take a flyer
on him and while a third or fourth round
probably I like his fit in that offense
you're not giving up a whole lot you
still fill your needs and you know that
rables just gonna see this big running
back running that fast I mean I yep I
want to drive those one of you mentioned
Clyde Edwards alaria ran a 4 6 flat he's
five foot seven that's okay with me
I think his shiftiness is the key is the
short air quickness the burst we didn't
see JK Dobbins like you guys mentioned
gender a swift ran a four for eight but
for me his workout was really really
impressive we saw the hands the past
catching ability out of the backfield
that makes him a pretty special player I
didn't feel like anyone at the running
back position necessarily like failed
like Tony Jones ran a four six eight
that's not great Zach Moss was hurt ran
a four six five but there wasn't any
there was no outlier where you were just
incredibly disappointed you know and I
think that's why you bring your guys to
compete in this because much like the
Senior Bowl we're talking about how
great everybody performed and then we're
mentioning guys oh well we didn't see
him you get one chance at your pro day
one chance to come do all this stuff
over again so you're saying if you only
had one shot one opportunity I think
once again the 40 is for TV the three
cone is what matters for running backs
over and over again that's the number
that really matters now if you're going
you know borderline for eight at running
back there might be some issues there
and you know Tony Jones is a guy that
left Notre Dame early and I know I was
personally scratching my head why and
then at the combine ran really really
slow and still asking myself why but
once again Jonathan Taylor DeAndre swift
these are the two guys for me that are
that
top of this runningback class / JK
Dobbins I like these guys a lot I'll
have them in my top 30 - I think they
can come in and play for you right away
at a really really high level I think
the only question teams have about Swift
is you know load management really he's
somebody that felt like Georgia for
whatever reason used even when he wasn't
banged up as more of a rotational guy
maybe like it's cuz we're running back
so they were yes yeah I agree
do you guys think that these running
backs can work their way into the first
round
I think Swift is gonna go first round I
think Jonathan Taylor is probably gonna
go first ring yeah I think somebody will
talk themselves into how safe of a
player Jonathan Taylor is I mean just
phenomenal character phenomenal work at
the great athlete you've set it for two
months if Derek Henry leaves the Titans
Jonathan Swift should be their pick at
29
yeah right yeah I'm like you know I
think that the Dolphins see one of these
guys and say man this could change our
office right now one of these guys Swift
or Taylor can change our offense we're
gonna pull the trigger at 18 and then
that's gonna force some of these other
teams to say well we were wanting a
running back now we're gonna have to
take one in the first round and I think
light Edwards Alerus the top 50 pick I
know that might not be a popular draft
Twitter opinion but I think he's gonna
be a top 50 pick I think so too I think
the contact balance is phenomenal I mean
it's funny they had Mark Ingram as a
guest analyst last night that's exactly
who Edwards Hilaire is exactly catches
ball very well out of the backfield
yeah a player that's been linked to
Melos team and can't stated chiefs
anthony mcfarland did very very well for
four four and the 40 he had an
exceptional three cut only 11 running
backs performed in the three cone so
even when you look at oh you was top ten
three cone
everyone was it's like when you go to
hydrated top 20 in my class right there
were 18 kids in your class exactly so I
think that that is a little bit skewed
but Anthony McFarland we've called him a
little Booker on the show a lot he has
had a really really good workout here
this week you're just really graduated
with 18 kids on Estela might have yeah
they're 18 I had like 44 I graduated 450
Wow that's like our whole town yes right
crazy anyways look how far we've mean I
was gonna say it's unbelievable
impressive thank you one other guy
didn't I do well and with someone we've
talked a lot about on the show so I want
to bring him up tre Adams offensive
tackle from Washington
three years ago he looks like used to be
a top ten pick and really it's just it's
to see the way that he's you know he's
broken down he's injuries he can't move
anymore and I think we saw that you know
we were supposed to be the senior bowl
and he got hurt and it's just it's not
good and I think we're to the point
where we probably won't talk about tre
Adams anymore because I don't know that
he's draftable at this point he's just
like you said he's so banged up in two
years ago here's a top tackle coming out
like we thought he was gonna come out as
a junior be a top-10 pick now we're
sitting here two years later I don't
know if he gets trapped it either like
you love the size but I can't move yeah
it's frustrating I know we've talked
about him on mock draft Monday and every
time you know that name comes up the
question is well however is medicals and
the problem is when you have back
injuries when you have lower body
surgeries and injuries it just feels
like everything is caught up to him and
it is a shame and I hope somehow he
bounces back but in a really good
offensive line class where you don't to
take medical risk on these other guys
it's it's simply gonna hurt I think at
best we're looking at the fifth sixth
seventh round yeah I agree
all right let's take a break we come
back the funniest guy on Twitter it's
gonna be amazing and I let's just ask
him football questions no impersonation
it's just football
just straight Colts talk the whole time
we'll be back right after this are we
are back live at Tooting Brewing Company
in Indianapolis Indiana and we are so
happy to be joined by I've been sitting
like you are right now the funniest
[ __ ] guy on Twitter and no crash but
also I don't know I was telling you
there night I think I've been following
you about a month you have over a
hundred and fifty thousand followers now
I think you had like six thousand when I
started following you yeah no I know I
suck back then we were nervous you're
gonna bail like I don't know we thought
the network would steal you or something
and you just sit up there with eyes in
the entire time but we're happy you're
here man hello thank you thanks for
having me this is awesome
real you've been doing we always joked
called the carwash you've been doing a
ton of media all week how tired are you
of doing impressions right now I mean
you can't really ever get tired of it
because it's part of the part of the
business
all right it's part of the the brand at
this point yeah I at the same time it's
like I'm how many times can you get
people to be like okay so Nick Saban
what does you think on this and then you
know you kind of run out of things to do
right I'm sure it's very annoying though
when people see you on the street like
you come on here and we say hey we do
your
cow hard and pressing you're like it's
kind of what I signed up for sure well
when you're at the mall and somebody's
like hey that's a Cowherd guy how
annoying is that so far I haven't got
too many cowherd guys if anything it'll
just be like backwards hat guy and I'll
beg backwards that guy you know I mean
but mostly it's coach oh that's where
I'll get a lot of people they like go
Tigers and then I'll have to hit them
with ya I've come back with let go
Bibles what's the most surprising one
you've been asked to do like is there
any impression you're like I don't even
know who that is
like I've been any weird interaction
there's some people who want me to dive
into hockey hold on okay doc Hamrick is
probably the one you know it's like
players I'm like guys no one watches
hockey I know right and so those but
then like Taiwan cameo right because
it's just you know nice way to pay for a
couple is the name but yeah people will
send me stuff that I've never done you
know they'll send me like Shannon Sharpe
or George Bush I'm like like that's not
a part of that's not a part of what I do
I don't know what you want from me like
I got a Bob Uecker one the other day
from major league you know and they were
like they were like just do the just a
bit outside and so I just rip what I
thought was you know I was like right
but then I was just seeing after I got
done with that I was just like I've
never done that before
thanks for following you know if you
have any other ones you want me to do
I'll do it but what age and which funny
we asked football players this way hey
what age did you think you were playing
the NFL yeah at what age did you think
you would be making people laugh on
Twitter pretending to be someone else
like I'm not you know so I get dick when
I say it like that but doing impressions
no I mean I've been telling people a lot
like I was always like that living room
impersonate her right like that so my
buddies are here right now like I would
always do teachers or their parents or
you know coaches that we had you know
what I mean and everybody get a little
bit of a laugh out of it but then reals
like well I kind of want to make some
money and like do things like this for a
living then I was like man I got to
start hitting people that people are
familiar with that are out there right
because that's what people care about
so really over the last year is when I
started diving into that
little bit more and going after not
going after but you know you taking on
different people to try to do and yeah
so it's been about a year it how many
characters do you have right now that
you do or people whatever you that I
feel good about I don't know probably
seven or eight I don't know uh yeah I'd
say about that maybe ten that I feel
like yeah about but you know I have my
go twos but price seven or eight I'd say
yeah I know you started doing a little
bit more not just specific impressions
but more generic things like the the
teacher yeah press conference right
first date press conference do you enjoy
that stuff a little more because it's
it's not tied to just one person you
could it's a little more creativity
involved for sure yeah like one that we
did this week it was like the 20/20
version of a combine interview right and
like joke of it was you know no one
really knows what goes on in these
interviews with these GM's and coaches
and players here this week and so I was
thinking it's 20/20 everybody's so
obsessed with social media now they want
to talk about tick-tock with these guys
and that was kind of a joke behind it so
yeah for sure like those things that you
know you don't have to hear people say
well you don't even so anything like ooh
more like the sticks gettin old it's
like hey I can come up with some
original funny stuff that you only mean
so definitely I I enjoy those skits even
more than doing impressions anyone got
Mattie you you have for doing them
because that's a risk right of like
because you're you're trying to sound
like them but you're also kind of making
fun of them at the same time sure but
like the way I look at is that the
reason that I feel like I can do these
people so well is because I'm so
familiar with them and for me to be
familiar with them that means that
they're doing something good right that
means that I follow them a lot you know
I mean like so to me it's a compliment
you know and Cowherd even said that on
his show and like Chris D'Elia he's my
favorite comedian he shouted me out a
couple times and I think as he gets it
that like the only reason I know it that
well is because I'm watching all the
time you know if I didn't care it wasn't
a fan then I wouldn't be able to do it
as well but no no one has gotten mad at
me
Alabama fans have gotten mad at me
they're yeah you know they they're of
they're a butthurt type they you know
they didn't they're they're down in the
dumps because LSU beat them and they
didn't make it a playoff for the first
time in you know since the playoff
existed and so then on top
of it having me you know do kocho making
fun of them that did not sit well so
they they are not the happiest with me
it's kind of a split crowd there with
the Bama people you ever been to
Tuscaloosa no you know I did say I'm
going to Baton Rouge in November and I
great choice absolutely cannot wait it's
good well if you want to you should go
to Baton Rouge in September when they
play Texas that's what I mean I mean my
wife's over there can we do that and we
make that happen in September she gives
a thumbs-up all right we're good right
yeah
all right be down there with them to see
cojo obviously since the impressions you
do are a lot of sports media people yeah
you're a big sports fan but when we got
to spend some time with you here we
assumed Colts because we ran indeed yeah
but you told your Steelers fan just yeah
explain that how you became a Steelers
fan and and what that's been like yeah
die-hard Steelers fans sorry to my guy
right there in the in the Browns Jersey
and need any more like of a letdown yeah
I know I know you know my dad like
classic you know he grew up in
Indianapolis in the 70s they didn't have
the Colts right so the Steelers were the
team funny enough his little brother is
a die-hard Cowboys fan so you know they
picked the two squads that were popular
at the time roll with them but it's also
funny because I got tired of you know
people being like well once you're the
coolest you'll have any time for
Pittsburgh I just started saying yeah my
dad's from Pittsburgh well two times I
met Pat McAfee I met Chris Ballard and
both times I had Steeler stuff on each
one of them said oh why are you Steelers
fan my dad's from Pittsburgh oh really
what part the south side no idea you
know finally I'm just like whatever I'm
just gonna stop telling that lie and but
that's yeah me we just he grew up with
it and then I grew up with it and we
roll with it any Steelers players you've
you'd like working on do you just we
should had your wife come on does he
like practice in the mirror in the
bathroom and you like walk in and like
who the [ __ ] here with him and it's oh
no it's just well yeah and sometimes
like she'll be sitting and like if I'm
doing impression time you know I kind of
just like honey can you go back into the
bedroom she sat in the couch a couple
times and I'm doing them and I just get
self-conscious because she's kind of
looking at me and I don't like stop it's
impression
but me time what I don't know it I don't
know they noise cancel really good it
was a smile so I think you're all right
we're all right do you have like a
number of videos you try to hit a week
or what's like the day to day look like
for you
I mean honestly like it's just yeah I
mean as many as I can you know it's just
just because it's like how do you see
people grow how do you see youtubers
grow it's putting out daily stuff for
their following to continue to keep
coming back to so that's that's kind of
the goal is daily or every other day and
just something that's quick and punchy
and topical you know that try to make
people a lot of fast sure there's a
bloopers reel somewhere I keep them with
my phone and I'll share them with maybe
my wife in one of my other buddies
uh-huh but don't I don't let the
bloopers reel out because a lot of times
I'll be right in the middle one and I'll
forget I'm gonna say or I'll be right in
the middle one and I'm like that doesn't
sound like it and I'll just you know
golf on a little tangent so it's you
know it could be kind of ugly yeah yeah
I mean we were just talking about how
how crazy it is like being I guess a
Twitter comedian and also most
importantly how you're following
following spiked like skyrockets you get
any weird like requests or DMS or offers
as that continues to happen where it's
like overwhelming are you on Instagram
first off yeah cuz that's open DMS I
don't know if your Twitter DM is are
open yeah that's we're gonna get really
crazy actually a Browns fan actually
tweeted at me one time was like open
your theme's coward I was like fine I
did they're open and so then I opened it
up and yeah it's pretty funny
you know the typical kind of things
either like hey come on the podcast or
hey you know do you have any
representation or hey how are you check
my nude pics here and I'm like woah woah
woah woah woah woah I'm sorry it's like
one of those weird like spam accounts
you know so you just just see it and
delete and get rid of it but essentially
those are like the three categories it's
like podcast representation spam porn
accounts how much media are you doing I
mean I this week you've obviously done a
lot because we're all here they're local
but I mean that's obviously did the best
way to build a following especially
outside of here yeah so is that
something where your
are you overwhelmed with it yet cuz it
can become pretty overwhelming at times
yeah I mean about a month or two ago
like I would you know try to do as many
shows as I can you know one because I
like to obviously separately get the
exposure but Horace hello I mean I
remember being 20 21 22 I mean brilliant
Tillis last year like I was always the
one reaching out to get people on the
show right so then when there's people
you know wanting to have me it's like
holy [ __ ] this is an honor of course
like yeah come on but then it got to a
point you know where it's just like I
can't you know I can't do and it's crazy
to think about like good lord well I
mean like what you guys are like big
Caterpie if - you mean like how many of
those requests y'all get it's just
insane to think about how many and how
often that happens and like it puts in
perspective to where it's like hey sorry
21 year old college kid like don't feel
bad your time will come but like we just
can't do all of them yeah I mean so
they're about 20 guys over here they're
gonna ask you yeah hey we come on our
pod
there you go so you said your Chiefs fan
though I am so rats we're from Missouri
right and I'm a Chiefs fan of Bennett
fan for about two years though alright
just the mahomes era Yeah right as soon
as and I hated my homes but as soon as
you got drafted yeah what was your you
know we don't talk about and but ever
since I started watching players like
man this guy is actually really good at
football and I just found myself rooting
for them so I'm not like one of those
fans who's been waiting this whole life
yeah two years was a long wait for me
sure yeah okay well you're honest about
it that's cool yeah that's I try to be
right
what was your guys's comp on my home's
always love like in Indy sorry I'm
taking over here please know in Indy I
am just like I'm big on love let's play
let's make it happen you can't sit on
draft picks forever Chris Ballard you
know like we with that just just stop
doing this well let's trade back and
we'll stock up on fourth of fifth round
pick dude at some point you got to just
make a move he's a hoarder
like he could go on the show hoarders
and it's just about how the driver wants
to make a draft selection yeah let's
make a move yeah right so what do we
think Jordan love 13 trade up and get
him I am
I'm on that Bob I think that's what
they'll do but I don't I don't know if
they should do it okay you know I threw
seventeen pics this past year that's a
problem for me it's a lot of happy had
like a whole unit I know that I give the
excuses a new coach always get all tears
but the problem is we'll all see here we
don't really like Jordan love he made
all these interceptions mistakes and
then he'll go to the Colts may i oh [ __ ]
that's a really good situation that's
good for the great offensive line as
we're running back some receivers and
then he'll go be a Pro Bowler in year
three and that's how mahomes was I think
all of us had like concerns about
mahomes and they were all based around
if the Browns drafted him at two and
made him play right away he would I
don't think he would fail but it
wouldn't be here this match again like
you said fit read playmakers you know
not the Browns sorry
so we're talking about the raffle at how
nervous does Joe burrow make you going
to the Bengals dude I am like I'm ready
for him to John Elway Eli Manning you're
hoping rain there's got to be a way you
can you can get involved in this
I'm not hoping I'll do whatever Joe
whatever it is number and do your coach
on call and I'll be like hey don't don't
play with the [ __ ] bag you know I
mean I think you could pull it off yeah
III know I have some connections there
but man that's I know it's tough because
I love Joey be you know like the rest of
the country and you know nothing besides
Alabama people I just kind of fell in
love with him and and I don't want to go
to bingos because I don't want have to
root against him so we'll see what is
your Baker Mayfield take I mean good as
a rookie not so good this pasture the
look on your face is like great this is
where Colin Cowherd we do we kind of
share the same you know I'm not gonna go
to the extent that cowherd goes on Baker
but the wins if you want to be honest
about I don't think anybody has been
more vocally against yeah I hate Baker
Mayfield really yeah sure okay I don't
what are there eight billion people in
this earth he's like the top person for
me see here's the thing for me with
Baker I respect and admire the whole you
six foot or five foot ten like walk-on
Heisman winner first pick like right
that's all you know any mean like we all
dreamed of doing that were 12 years old
perspect
but what I don't get it and what I don't
fall in line with is all the hype that
especially came last offseason right
going into this year and rightfully so I
think it's gonna fall off but I'm with
you I just I never I was like what are
we what are we doing here guys like
we've seen this experiment before and it
I didn't think was gonna work in
Cleveland after you know last two years
ago when they were going into this obj
and hype offseason and coming into 2019
and they fell flat on their face like we
thought they would and now it's like
we're right back to where we expected
Baker to be honestly with a new coach
and a new GM again again I mean it's
just do it circle that's where you know
you get into the ESPN post and all these
things and different shows on different
networks talking about how you know he
can change the game he can change the
face of this sport it's like guys 17 is
a starter no I mean when you have a home
is a little more Jackson yeah sorry John
Watson like they're good quarterbacks
out there we don't need to make the
number one overall pick into this good
quarterback yeah elite level play right
now right so what'd you guys think about
my Steelers we I'd love your Steelers I
think getting you right now Mason
Rudolph is the most punchable human
being in the show I'd agree so get
getting it rid of him I think we'll be
good yeah I think I mean they could be
explosive I want them to drive for
running back I think James Connors I
think the other night I'm not a believer
in his the rest of the tools are there
TJ watt is amazing minka is amazing like
they there's some really really good
players there Devin Busch is going to be
phenomenal
this should they should have been a
playoff team this year if Ben hasn't
they almost well yeah I mean so yeah I
love duck but I don't know how long
that's gonna last either so they gonna
draft a quarterback I think you have to
at some point that this quarterback
class just sucks so if you don't draft
one on the second round like you're
you're getting a guy that's in extreme
developmental type player yeah you're
hating duck hot Jason heard somebody
interest
I very interesting for them yes if Big
Ben though isn't the size of Makai
Becton when he comes into training camp
but you have a really good chance he's
looking burly these days but if Big Ben
comes in and gets healthy and you draft
jaylen I mean they have a good roster
outside of that as we saw last year it's
a mate it's amazing they almost made the
playoffs with the two quarterbacks of
they were rolling out sure good mike
tomlin it I was gonna say it's funny I
was on I was on part I might take a
couple years ago and they're like who's
the most underrated coach in the NFL and
I said Mike Tomlin and they were like
they [ __ ] on me like Mike Thomas
I was like yeah like I think Mike Talman
is and then I started doubting myself
like was that a dumb answer like I think
it was a good answer and I feel like
it's come back to that you know where
what he imagined he camp Antonio Brown
in line for like six years that's a de
la thing that's something that's my best
take that I've ever had and I also take
business from the very beginning of all
that stuff last offseason with Antonio
Brown and everybody blame it Big Bend
everybody blaming the Steelers I said
you guys are all insane you're wrong
Antonio Brown is a cancerous dude who is
just he is the problem he is the problem
and everybody was you know no you're
wrong it's Babla and then you didn't
even play snap do you play snap dude so
I just had to get that out there that I
was on I was on that side had it for
I've been anti Antonio Brown since and I
will continue to be I was a good choice
yeah man thank you for coming by we
appreciate people can follow you on
twitter
agile Molinaro yes no no no numbers no
same one Instagram yes oh that's smart
if you wanted to mmm something really
stranger gonna be closed as soon as this
show ends but thank you for coming by
awesome man and get ready to be asked to
do coach o or Nick Saban to everyone
here so for sure luck with that we'll be
back right after this we are back live
at UT Brewing Company in Indianapolis
Indiana thanks to our guy Joey for
coming on the show definitely follow him
you're not gonna be disappointed but we
have laughing unless you don't like
laugh or unless you're in Alabama or
Cleveland Browns fan didn't expect that
but I loved it we should have that's
ready kitchens fan base just not fans of
him is he a Giants fan let's see what
happens there we have draft on draft
questions let's start them let us know
your name
I know everyone by their Twitter handle
and then shoot us your question hi my
name is Logan Stapleton I'm from Seattle
and I'm a big Seahawks fan and I'm
wondering the likelihood that the
Seahawks rescinded avian and if they
don't or if they're not players for him
what's another big-name free agent they
could go out and sign yeah I think you
guys are 50/50 you have as good of a
shot as anybody what makes it difficult
is you trade that you trade the picks
forgot you can't franchise tag right so
that makes it tough but I think because
that John Schneider is gonna know you
gonna have to come to the table pretty
heavy handed to get him you guys have a
lot of free agents on defense as well so
I look at it as they're gonna do
everything they can to keep him if he
wants to go to the southeast you can't
really stop him you know if he wants to
go to the Dolphins they can pay him or
the Colts you can't compete with that
but I've liked Seattle we'll come in
good on that market when it comes to the
free agent class it's him it's Yannick
and Gok way and we've talked about this
on a couple shows ago it's not the
greatest edge rusher for agent class but
it is pretty strong at the top and you
guys are all so you got LJ Collier who
is the first-round pick and has not done
anything at all so there's that two of
you might be looking at other than pono
you might have a complete d line redo
that's why I like Marlin Davidson a lot
for them in the first round is get an
athletic pass rusher up front but if you
lose Jadeveon if you lose drawn read
there's give me some money to spend and
I don't know if Yannick would be willing
to go from Jacksonville to Seattle that
sounds like one hell of an upgrade to me
just personally but he would be the guy
we'll go after I think it's gonna be
hard for cloudy to look at other teams
and be like this situations better than
what I haven't see at all I know I'm
gonna win nine games I'm probably gonna
make the playoffs so I think that if I'm
betting on it I would say Seattle keep -
yeah I would think so - and I do think I
know Matt said this in one of our
midweek shows that the Giants and Colts
expect to be big players those two have
hoarded cap space especially the Colts
like no others where they want to go out
and do something stupid and give him a
number that no one else can match they
can do it but I think Melo just made a
great point he was really good in
Seattle and honestly he was he was good
with Houston not always healthy but he
was a different level of good in Seattle
both against the run and as a pass
rusher where that scheme fits him really
well it seemed like the training staff
was on page with him which is something
that wasn't always the case in Houston
so starting over new again in the NFL I
don't know if that's the best choice
personally for him when you look at
other options I would keep an eye on how
far edge FNS falls in this draft because
maybe they can make a play for him
they're probably just on the outside
looking in but in terms of scheme fit
and instant you know we can play from
day one get you eight sacks and stop the
run that's the guy that would be my
replacement through the girafft
all right thanks dude up next guys with
blaze Linux my one question for you guys
is can you name one prospect that would
take a team from a playoff contender to
a Super Bowl favorite in the first round
oh wow it's a great question that is a
great question
I feel like Kenneth Murray to Green Bay
would just because like that was there
one hole and I think they're only gonna
get better with Aaron Rodgers I'm Matt
Lafleur in year two so if I could put
Kenneth Murray to the Packers like I
feel like there might be the best team
in the NFC so you're a Super Bowl
content like a playoff team yeah we know
you're gonna do that with Aaron Rodgers
but I think that puts you over the top
it's harder to let you know like if
Henry rug's goes to the Eagles yes like
that's amazing
but it's Carson Wentz gonna be healthy
which version of Carson Wentz are we
gonna get I think the key there and I
was actually gonna steal Henry rugs if
he somehow fell to the Saints or if the
Saints can get really good quality out
of that number two receiver I think that
there are supervolcano Jefferson I mean
they pretty much already are or if one
of these running backs can go to a team
like maybe the bills take a chance on
him or somebody like that I think that
receiver and running back would really
set a lot of these teams over the top I
think for me would be the Ravens at
linebacker you know I know Matt brought
up Kenneth Murray I think that's a
really nice fit not sure if he makes it
there what Patrick Queen can do in
coverage is almost unrivaled in this
class and I think that would take a
great Ravens defense and just put them
over the top so those are one of the
teams that obviously I think all of us
expected them to be in the Super Bowl
this year they might lose match you down
in four agencies so maybe they look at
some of the pass rushers at that pick
but they're really one more piece away
on defense and just honestly being a
little more consistent in the big games
to make a Super Bowl and if my Niners
draft is safety I don't think they draft
thirty-one playoff contender not I'm
trying to make this happen my gentleman
Jonathan Taylor
Dan Kiefer I got a two-part question
I'll try not to be too selfish first off
thank you for the beers you clear
the way to my heart and then I'm curious
at the top of show you talked about how
Dwayne Haskins could potentially be on
the move if they decide to go
quarterback so I'm wondering where you'd
slot him in this class and then for
Connor specifically that people are
getting restless we would like to know
when we're getting our sticky chug from
you well I'll answer that part first I
tell you I'm building suspense like as
long as I possibly can
so maybe tailgate tour 2020 maybe not
let's say I'm gonna keep the people
waiting instance Melo is gonna get his
tattoo while Connor chugs that's
actually a really fair point I will do
the sticky chug
why Melo is getting the Josh Allen [ __ ]
stamp so that's not gonna happen
attitude what was your other question I
never join Haskins where would he slot
in this class sorry
so obviously Jo burrow would be tops for
me too will be second I don't I would
not have him above Justin Harbor or
dreadin love I think the conversation is
does he come in what I think he would be
ahead of Jacob Eason he would be ahead
of Jake Fromm being ahead of jaylen hurt
so you look like the fifth quarterback
in this class is where I would have him
and I've gone back and looked at my
Haskins notes over the last 12 hours
because we knew that this was gonna come
up with trade stuff and and I said it on
the Friday show he was the breaking
point for me as a round 2 player last
year and I liked him in certain schemes
and hated him in others so I think even
that like where he slots in is so scheme
specific so he's gonna be an interesting
guy if there is a trade market do do the
Bears trade a second-round pick for him
do does Tampa try to get involved and
trade for him and there's a lot of
different directions I could go and I
think what happened with Rosen last year
that that might actually hurt his value
too so I don't know if you are getting a
very good second-round pick look back
and to your point and I actually thought
this were he gonna hurt Rosen was they
were trying to trade him draft weekend
you need to like if you're gonna
straight Dwayne Haskins you need to do
it in two weeks you don't want to wait
and do it during the draft when teams
really already have a plan and they're
not able to think and be flexible or
they've already filled their quarterback
need we haven't talked a lot about like
the Cardinals did Josh Rosen badly and I
know he's like he's not playing in Miami
they whatever they did him no favors by
waiting to trade him that weekend yeah I
mean let's be real he goes through a
Miami situation where they were never
rebuilding around Josh Rosen they took
him on as a flyer it
felt like but just to answer that
question I think I would have Haskins
right between Jordan Love and Justin
Herbert I've been pretty vocal that I'm
just not a big Justin Herbert fan and I
think there's really two impact starters
out of this class and burrow into a
Jordan love is a wild card that I
understand if a team takes a chance on
and I like him I had Haskins we're
talking about this I think yesterday
18th overall in last year's class which
for a quarterback is it's okay so once
again you know he's okay but I don't
understand why they would take to it in
that spot over him all right next up the
man the myth thanks guys again for
throwing all these events seeing
everybody after mobile um Andrew
Harbaugh sorry didn't reduce myself last
time a couple of small school guys Cal
Duggars hasn't tested yet Ben Barch has
where do you think they kind of fit into
the fold here now Bart I don't I don't
think gets out of day to do you think
Duggar though if he tests well today
could jump into back end around 1 I
don't think he could jump into
background 1 it wouldn't surprise me but
it feels like this safeties are gonna
drop a little bit this year I think
Xavier McKinney we had thought a lot
like at Dallas at 17 but again the
effect of these tackles and quarterbacks
going early is Javon Kinlaw could fall
to Dallas in which case you take him and
then save your McKinney Falls to the
Niners of the Chiefs at the back end so
to your question Andrew I think that
Duggars a really really good player for
me the line between him and grant Dale
Peters almost non-existent that's how
much I like Kyle Tucker but I expect
they're gonna both be early-round to
type picks big Barch is the the biggest
questions were a level of competition
right and he goes to the Senior Bowl and
he looks like he belongs I mean you
could have put in Ohio State home but on
that kid and you would have thought he
started for the Buckeyes he was that
good I agree with you I think he's
probably gonna be a round 3 pick I would
be surprised if he gets a today too
because and especially for the way my
board Falls right now after Austin
Jackson there's a big gap to the next
tackle and so guys like Barch or if
you're a zone team ezra Cleveland or
Isiah Wilson at right tackle Matt pert
from UConn someone's gonna raise up the
board even if we don't feel like they
should be ranked that high yeah I agree
with everything you just said it's
always nice when that happens yep
I have to do anything when that me yeah
not that much different for me Duggar
firmly in the second round really no
matter what he does at the combine I I
don't think I'll move them up to first
round because I'm not expecting this to
be like some record breaking kind of
performance even though he is a good
athlete bartsch around three to four I
think you know once again there are a
lot of really good names at offensive
line and I think that's right firmly
where he'll be after that it's almost
two waves will get before his name comes
off the board all right last one here we
go
yeah so Austin are from Cincinnati but
I'm a Browns fan so it seems like one of
the long storylines of this draft has
been the rise of the tackles Browns pick
at ten how likely do you think it is
that that run of the top four tackles
ends at nine or before and the Browns
you left empty-handed and if so do you
think they should pick and Isaiah
Simmons there or trade back late
first-round pick up an Austin Jackson or
something like that I think you guys are
in good shape to get one of the top four
tackles I really do we run through
scenarios all the time sometimes on the
show sometimes it's for an article
sometimes it's just your board on the
road and you're thinking about where
people are gonna get drafted so I mean
we feel pretty confident the Giants
could take one of four it's 50/50 they
could take one of four the great news
for you guys is next it's Arizona at
eight is where we think the next tackle
comes off the board the Browns are
probably gonna get the third best tack
on this class it's just other teams have
invested Carolina at seven they've
invested in Taylor Mont and they've
invested in Greg little you know even
Jacksonville they've invested in those
tackles watch John Taylor Laster in the
second round so I think the Browns are
in a good good shape to get even if you
got the fourth best tackle that's Andrew
Thomas and he's pretty good you know so
I think I think you guys are alright I
don't feel like they're in a spot where
they would have to trade now the
question will be what angel Berry values
because none of us know they could look
at the board at nine and say this would
be crazy but they could say tackles
aren't first-round positions let's trade
back you never know I mean you really
don't so I think that's what we will try
to learn this offseason is how Andrew
berry places priority and value on
positions yeah I agree
I think they're in position right now
without any trades they will get one of
the top four tackles and if not looking
at guys like Josh Jones I think that
he's pretty damn good to Austin Jackson
top 15 buzz about him
they will be in position to take a
tackle maybe not one of the top four but
I do think they will yeah I think Andrew
Thomas is probably the name to keep an
eye on I mean the way I look at this
class Jedrek will should be the first
tackle taken and I think he will be
Makai pectin teams are gonna love him no
matter what else you know whatever
whatever anyone else thinks of him how
wrong he is how many true pass sets he's
taken
Tristan works just blew it up here I
mean he absolutely killed it so I think
they're right in the sweet spot where
they get the end of the run it would
have to cause some kind of trade up over
them because teams know the Browns are
looking at tackles I mean you have the
Jets at 11 maybe they think they have to
move there's teams behind them Costanzo
coming back to the Colts probably makes
you feel a little safer than you used to
because the Colts had a lot of capital
to come up again top tackle but I feel
as long as they want one that's the
question I feel pretty good about the
Browns getting one all right I Becton
just feels like the Browns pick at 10 if
he makes it yeah if he makes it that's
that's gonna be the key but never see
Baker Mayfield I think I think Tristan
Dwarfs from an analytics perspective
will be pretty impressive
you know just the weeks pass the
Cardinals though shouldn't shouldn't
look at that alright that is our show
thank you again to everyone who came out
thank you again to to D Brewing Company
for hosting us thank you to joy for
coming on we're gonna hang out have a
good time so if you have questions come
find us otherwise vermelho for Connor
we'll talk to you guys real soon